hello everyone could I have your
attention please for getting ready to
start I am Marika Michael's a member of
the board of directors of the Friends of
the library and on behalf of the friends
I'm very pleased to welcome you all here
tonight we are so pleased to have Jack
bass with us dr. bass has been intrigued
by Strom Thurmond for over four decades
having met and more than 40 years ago
when covering the senator as a newspaper
reporter dr. bass as most of you know is
a professor of humanities and Social
Sciences at the College of Charleston he
has a PhD in American Studies from Emory
University and is author or co-author of
seven books about the American South he
co-authored this book with Marilyn
Thompson a former Washington Post
reporter and now an editor at the
Lexington herald-leader in Kentucky and
by the way after speaking tonight dr.
bass will be signing copies of his book
and books will be for sale in the back
of the room so please welcome the man
that Strom Thurmond so kindly referred
to once as a skunk dr. Jack bass senator
Thurmond and I thank you for the
wonderful introduction it is true he did
one for call me a skunk but was very
sensitive story I was working on and he
was unhappy about it but I learned
something very important about prom
Thurman in that situation the following
week I got a letter from him said dear
jack I thought you'd like to have a copy
of this book of memorials and
testimonials to our good friend Mendel
rivers former congressman from
Charleston course who recently died at
that time and they actually had my
obituary of Congressman rivers which
began the Charleston has long been known
for three great rivers he actually the
Cooper in the middle
but I'm a read a few excerpts from the
book and then open everything to
questions and my wife said I shouldn't
say that this is her favorite chapter
but so I won't but it was to be just the
first paragraph of chapter 5 says of all
the women with whom strom thurmond was
ever romantically linked none was more
deadly than sue Logue the trial judge
believed the murder that sent her to the
electric chair was quote the most
cold-blooded in the history of the state
it also generated enduring law legend
and myth about Thurman and and then is
anyone here from edgefield it y'all
everybody ought to take a trip to HBO
but edgefield really shaped Strom
Thurmond and is this this paragraph from
Roosevelt new dealer to death sentencing
state judge from liberal governor to
Dixiecrat candidate from choosing young
wives to stories of quote colored
offspring close quote from Party
switching Democrat to Republican savior
for Richard Nixon from civil rights
antagonists to supporter of a Martin
Luther King holiday from a deed a crash
landing and a lighter behind German
lines at Normandy to liberate a role at
Buchenwald from a direct challenge of
George Wallace to assaulting the Warren
Court and from a death house seduction
to padding journalists Sally Quinn's ass
Thurman lived and survived with the
boldness of an edge field man let me
just read the opening of the book as the
Senate began its impeachment trial of
President Bill Clinton in January 1999
Strom Thurmond provides presided over
the squaring end of Chief Justice
William Rehnquist the ninety six year
old senator from South Carolina appeared
a bit unsteady in his most public act as
President Pro temporary
of the Senate a mostly ceremonial
position but he understood that the
moment also contained a strong element
of irony here was the Congress of the
United States sitting in grave judgment
to determine whether the president of
was guilty of quote high crimes and
misdemeanors for conduct stemming from a
relationship with intern Monica Lewinsky
and here was Strom Thurmond a man who
had taken unabashed pride in achieving a
reputation for lechery that could put
Thurmond to excuse me that could put
Clinton to shame starting the show a
Titan of the republican party's
conservative wing Thurman had a clear
obligation to vote guilty but before the
trial began Thurman met with a few of
his closest advisors and ranted just as
he had in the old days these
conservatives he complained all this
judgmental stuff this is personal it's
nobody's business further as his
advisors were aware Thurmond harbored a
secret that he knew would emerge
eventually one that had the potential to
redefine his legacy forgiving admirers
would likely view this secret as
evidence of his determination to do the
right thing and to meet his personal
obligations his enemies would see it as
the ultimate hypocrisy living proof that
the Senators career as banner carrier
for the white supremacist dixiecrats and
his years opposing the civil rights
movement were the result of pure
political expedience Thurmond sometimes
ruminated about how the story would
break probably after his death it would
be bigger than anything in his life if
they could do this to Clinton he would
ask then what in the world would they do
and they finally learned the truth about
the one time segregationist illegitimate
black daughter Essie Mae
washington-williams once recalled
Armstrong Williams his trusted advisor
and a black man Strom laughed so hard at
the irony that his frail body rock
and tears rolled down his cheeks on July
first 2004 exactly a year after Strom
Thurmond's funeral the name SEMA was
chiseled into the stone base of the 17
foot tall Thurman statue on the
Statehouse grounds in Columbia South
Carolina it was added to that of his
other children so now open it the
questions
ok
would you talk about the influence of
Rob fig own sermons life multi Robert
fig was a distinguished Charleston
lawyer he wrote many of Strom Thurmond
speeches he actually argued for the
state of South Carolina in the case of
Brown versus Board of Education and made
a good lawyer Lee argument he later
became Dean of the law school at the
University of South Carolina where he
served as many years and also served as
and as an unofficial adviser to many of
the governors of the state and Strom
Thurmond's inauguration speeches
governor was one of the most progressive
documents you will see in the state's
history and Robert fig wrote that point
and he was there also in strong made his
Dixiecrat speech when he declared that
they're not enough troops in the army to
force the southern people to accept a
Negro race into their home's into their
schools into their churches and into
their swimming pools and fig always
deeply regretted that Thurman you know
made that total reversal of course from
being a liberal Democrat which is what
he was a liberal New Deal Democrat but
Thurman had a keen eye for judging
public opinion and the only thing he
ever said was maybe he said some things
there that he shouldn't have but he
denied that he ran a racist racist
campaign but I felt that his funeral
that he that when he and Thurman planned
that funeral in detail and when they
sang ameya played amazing grace it
struck me that that was Thurman
statement you know about Amazing Grace
how great they are to save a wretch like
meat but but fig was it was a very
significant figure in Strom Thurmond and
and he knew Thurman before he became
governor knew him well Thurman was a
state court judge he was a state senator
before that I mean he had the longest
most enduring political figure in 20th
century America his core beliefs he
seemed to have been on both sides of the
issue did he deeply believed one side of
the other was he just a political animal
it's a good question and it's difficult
to answer I think he did have some core
beliefs but I think sometimes they
changed in whatever position he took he
really internalized it in a sense and
did believe it Jack as you know as strom
thurmond was a strong supporter of Bob
Jones University a fundamentalist
institution which opposed the
intermingling of the races to what
extent do you think strahm's views
similar to bob jones were biblically
based oh I think Thurman's views were
more politically based than biblically
based and and it wasn't it was not the
position of Bob Jones on race that
attracted Strom Thurmond it was Bob
Jones standing with a large number of
worshippers in this state who voted that
the same reason that you know that
President Bush went to bob jones
university when he campaigned in south
carolina for the before the Republican
primary before the two thousand election
I think it was a mean I think like
almost everything that Thurman did he
had the most keen political antenna you
automatically processed everything in
political terms the only the only
political person that I can think of who
matched Thurman in terms of just sheer
political instinct would be Bill Clinton
so what was Thurmond you said that he
was a product of Edgefield and when he
laughed at the paradox of being the
father of a black child while at the
same time presiding over the the trial
of the president was he in essence so
sure of himself that he could he felt no
need to be consistent that paradox was
just a basic human character and he was
so sure of himself he could afford to be
paradoxical I think you analyze it very
well and Thurman also was someone who
compartmentalised his life you know his
relationship with SE and this is
Washington Williams that's the name she
goes by his s he weaves her husband's
name was Williams and she goes by our
first name when she was a child she went
by the name of ser SMA and her and she
uses the name this he made
washington-williams when she is talking
to a group but his relationship with her
you know he may had a relationship with
her it goes back to 1941 when she was 15
years old is when he first actually met
her and as she has said you know he
asked her about her plans what she
wanted to do in the future and she she
talked to he talked to her I won't say
lectured but he talked to her about good
health and good eating habits and
getting plenty of exercise and those
things that were tops on his mind with
almost everyone Strom was a man who
really believed in physical fitness and
you know he lives he remained a u.s.
senator passed his 100th birthday but in
the end in the end that relationship for
both of them was emotionally unsatisfied
that's one of the interesting things and
and one reviewer of the book said it's
almost two books in one because it tells
a full story of Thurman's life but it
also has essays life in their
relationship and it as well
if you know him during his last years in
the Senate I often wondered how acute
his mind was during those days if his
staff was making all the decisions and
he was just mouthing them there was a
mix he certainly was slowed down in his
final years in the Senate and it's
reflected he resigned his chairmanship
of the Armed Services Committee and
withdrew from some of his activity but
he was not quote out of it some days
were better than others and he was you
know it's trauma had a real character
flaw it was vanity in the word was he
was just too vain to wear a hearing aid
so frequently he was not really aware
what people were saying and you might
carry on a conversation I say something
to him and he'd say so good to see you
again in the reaction of the listener it
wasn't for me with all of that
background was it he's out of it I talk
to them only once in his final days did
an earlier book called old strong and
just told him I'd like to spend you know
a day with him in Washington I didn't
really want the interviewing because I
knew he wasn't going to tell me anything
and we had plenty of interview material
and I'd interviewed him much in the past
as had my co-author Maryland Thompson
and he just said well I can't make
exceptions he said I'm getting a lot of
requests and so then I told him really
would like to talk to Thomas moss who
had worked who worked for him for 30
years he was a first black aide to a
congressman from this state and perhaps
in the south and I knew mr. moss before
senator Thurmond knew him and he said
the same thing he couldn't make
exception so I called mr. Moss who died
a year or two ago so now I can reveal
this I think and he laughed and said
referred to senators administrative
assistant and said said you know he said
Dukes a you right now unauthorized
biography and he laughed and said I
figured Jack bass right knee heel calf
is authorized or unauthorized
but Mr lost very intelligent man and so
he agreed to meet with me and I didn't
quote him in the book but I've got a lot
of tremendously useful information in a
tote senator thermos as soon as you know
you're told he knocked was anything bad
about you but he filled in a lot of
blanks that were important beyond legend
and anecdote to Strom Thurmond leave any
lasting legacy his impact he left a
lasting impact on American history that
tends to be unappreciated i covered the
1968 republican national convention in
miami beach and I covered the South
Carolina delegation for night newspapers
now knight-ridder and believe me Thurman
played the key role in Nixon getting the
nomination he held two southern
delegates against Ronald Reagan who got
in that race late and and and that's
when I learned something important about
Strom Thurmond means Thurman was all
over the place two-thirds the southern
delegates voted for Nixon on the first
ballot which he barely won Nelson
Rockefeller was a third candidate and
Thurman's message that's when I it not
until I got really started writing the
book that I really understand his
tremendous skill in taking a complex
political message and converting it into
a sound bite what he said to those
southern delegates was that a boat /
aegon is a vote for Rockefeller and they
got it and later in the general election
he told white Southerners who many of
whom were attracted to George Wallace
and many of whom voted for him but many
others heard Thurman would run that
segregationist third-party Santa to see
earlier he said a boat koalas is a vote
for Humphrey meaning Hubert Humphrey the
vice president the Democrat and and it
was that was very very helpful to
Richard Nixon in the general election
but in Miami Beach he was indispensable
and Thurman met privately with Ronald
Reagan I learned about it
from Harry death Thurman's almost alter
ego dense that he wouldn't the Reagan
wouldn't let him stay in the room so I
stood around the elevator in the hotel
and Senator Kingdom and I said Sunday I
understand you met with Governor Reagan
he said that's right and I said well
what did you tell him he saw told him
I'd be for him next time that's the
other big thing that the sermons in
terms of his first big historic impact
was his changing the shape of the
Republican Party and and tremendous
impact they're not only legislation his
legacy is pretty slim but in changing
the political culture of the country and
the direction of the Republican Party is
very significant secondly thermit
without Thurmond who just was like a cat
dog in the confirmation his very current
situation attack dog and the
confirmation hearings of Associate
Justice Abe Fortas I mean I heard on the
news tonight former this year in
committee chairman Orrin Hatch said
they've never been a filibuster in a
judicial you know confirmation hearing
where there was one at the end of the
fortis earrings and Strom Thurmond
participated in it but he was the attack
dog throughout the whole thing and it
really ended up with Fortis withdrawing
as a candidate for chief justice and the
impact of that was that Richard Nixon
ended up with four Supreme Court
appointments which ended up changing the
direction of the Supreme Court of the
United States and I do attribute that
the strong Thurman and whether you agree
or disagree with the result important
thing to me is to recognize the reality
of how it happened and why it happened
and and you know in one of Nixon's
four-point links was William Rehnquist
Chief Justice now
would you comment on the importance of
geography or place in Thurman's life and
career I mean if he had been born in
Ohio do you think he would have been
successful or if he had been born in
Charleston instead of Edgefield would he
have been a different person would there
been a different career trajectory there
I'm convinced that if Thurman had not
grown up in Edgefield he would have been
quite different I think edgy Oh had a
tremendous impact on midfield maybe the
most I mean I lived 10 years in Oxford
Mississippi and I can assure you
edgefield is far more fog Narian than
Faulkner jacques neau photography and
and also did an earlier biography of
Judge Frank Johnson in Alabama great
civil rights judge had tremendous impact
hero to the cast the deciding vote in a
Montgomery bus boycott case that really
launched the civil rights movement he it
was his court in him as judge who
allowed the Selma March that resulted
really in creating the climate for
passage of the Voting Rights Act he grew
up in Haleyville alabama in winston
county a county in which twice as many
men in the Civil War fought for the
Union Army they fought in the first
Alabama cavalry regiment of the United
States Army including two of his
great-grandfather's brothers and his
father which was a known as it what was
known as a mountain Republican he
regularly went to the National
Republican conventions and he met people
like Earl Warren and Herbert Brownell
and brown ellis attorney general
resulted in that appointment but I think
place really is important my the result
of doing those two books I feel that
much more strongly than I did before
you mentioned that yes trauma is was a
strong political force and he certainly
brought a lot of bacon back to South
Carolina but can you mention one
positive piece of legislation that he
sponsored that helped the entire country
well it depends upon how one views
positive but his probably most
significant actual legislation that he
introduced it became law is the warning
label that you find on bottles of wine I
don't let me let me just add to that
though I don't want to suggest that he
wasn't involved in legislation he was in
terms of committee work and so forth but
as far as initiating legislation that
was not where he left his mark tell that
story if you would please about how he
happened to sponsor that particular
legislation it's it's complex and I'm
not sure if I know all of it his wife
had a problem with alcohol at that time
she would really have an allergy and the
first time she drank wine it exposed
itself and and he was also always
anti-alcohol he would not have he was
not a teetotaler not a total teetotaler
at least but he did not drink whisky and
occasionally would have a beer and and
his he had begun to drink a little bit
of line because the doctor said it was
good for him but he and i think he was
since very sincere about you know the
warning labels about driving my drinking
but especially the impact of alcohol on
an expectant mothers and and strong was
also always very strong when he was
governor and even in the in the Senate
he was a strong support of equal rights
for women he voted for equal rights
amendment on his personal life there
were rumors about what happened between
him and Nancy that her name the last
what was the story there is you see it
well I think in in the end I think the
age difference in particular as he aged
and God you know you know she was 22
when she married him and he was 66 so
you fast-forward that 20 years she's 42
and he's 88 and and I think by that time
she had decided she wanted to live more
of her own life but they never divorced
and not only did they never divorce even
though separated they they maintained
considerable amount of contact personal
contact otherwise i right first like
that very tragically not when it was a
very powerful love story is married to
jean crouch she died of brain cancer at
age 33 and she was she was the powerful
influence on me in fact Harry dental it
said that strom thurmond never would
have switched to the Republican Party of
Jean Thurman had lived daughter died
before or after the law on alcohol I'm
not sure of that I'll have to have to do
some research on that it may have been
directly connected but I think she died
after but i'm not sure that his daughter
was his oldest daughter was killed very
tragically two weeks before graduating
from the University of South Carolina
when she was struck by he drunk driver
driving about 45 miles an hour in
downtown Columbia and and he and Nancy
went through that together they'd
already separated and so and and it's
that that is also a very poignant story
just they're going through that process
together and the prosecutor would be
carpooling and who later became
Democratic Party Chairman in South
Carolina and he was just very impressed
with the two of them and he was big and
he had always been a bitter enemy of
Thurman's and he was just very impressed
that you know the Thurmond been in his
90s really knew the law then it said
said I never realized the guy was so
smart
your book is about Strom Thurmond but he
was so overwhelmingly successful in
flannel ective office it in a way it's
about the people of South Carolina what
does it tell you about the people of
South Carolina in terms of what they
valued and what they were looking for
and how they might have compared with
voting populations elsewhere well you
know they had Strom Thurmond in the
United States Senate from South Carolina
for 48 years and four thirty six of
those years they had Fritz Hollings in
the United States Senate a strong
Democrat a strong national Democrat and
one of the things that both of them had
in common textile worker once explained
to me in Strom 72 campaign for
reelection cities for strong said he was
for strong Thurmond and I asked him why
he said because he stands up for what he
believes in even when he's wrong and and
he would always take a stand and
Hollings would always take a stand you
always knew where he stood you may agree
or disagree but you always knew where he
stood in that generated respect and then
you also had with Thurmond you know you
had the legendary constituent service
you know Borden's close to 800,000
request for from constituents a lot of
it very easy seen a lot of it was you
know social security related issues
member of family dying and trying to get
a son or daughter home from the military
and the phone never rang more than twice
in his office and anybody who wrote a
letter a response went out within 24
hours and every letter that went out of
his office was let us know if we can
help and everybody who died the
survivors got a letter from Strom
Thurmond with that statement in it in
one form or another and the other thing
he about Thurman was political boldness
that's rare you know there is a man you
he's 41 years old and as a volunteer in
fact he sort of sneaked aboard but he he
went in on the same mission as private
ryan went in on d-day in a glider behind
German lines
that's part of the whole edgefield
tradition but then he runs as a
third-party candidate for president of
the United States he switches parties he
gets elected only person history of the
United States to get elected to Congress
either house as a write-in candidate and
then he you know he took a portis on
just head on and then that the
Republican convention in 68 Thurman was
all over the place and you know what he
he would be a great person to have as
your ally in a fight and if you were
fighting against him you knew you had
somebody who knew how to fight that may
bring up my question because I'm
listening to this and he's a bit foreign
to me I'm from the Northeast but we all
knew who that was and I don't see in all
of this a significant and I'm not even
sure how to ask my question a
significant adversary I mean politicians
have to fight you know to get where to
get their positions but he has this long
long career with not much of any kind of
adversarial stop you have to read the
chapter on the campaign of the century
when Thurman ran for the Senate for the
first time in 1950 against US senator
olin Johnston at the end of sermons term
two years after he ran for president and
Thurman lost 12 years later Fritz
Hollings ran for the first time for the
US Senate against son a toll and
Johnston and he lost and Johnson was a
real New Deal Democrat so I think South
Carolina voters tend to look at the
personality of the person and judges in
a broad sense and part of it is they
want somebody they feel they can crust
that's sort of a follow-up to that would
you care to speculate on the impact on
strong political career had the
information about Miss Williams become
more general public knowledge say a
decade before that we wrote it in a book
the first biography of Thurman seven
years ago and a lot of people just a lot
of white people just didn't believe it
most black people knew about it and it
was just well that's strong I mean one
of the great stories this one Maryland
Thompson got in Edgefield untimely to
farmers standing on the street corner
just sort of looking at the traffic he's
looking at card going past the canova
would go and pass and finally one spit
some tobacco juice and said you hear the
one about strum and abortion bill first
nope so yellow Strom up the iron is
walking in his office in Washington lady
calls and the secretary said this woman
wants to talk to you Strom was kind of
busy said what said strong Strom was
kind of busy and said what she want she
said you forced to talk to you about the
borscht and bill and chrome just said
tell her to pay it now reimburse him
[Laughter]
but he also was somebody who campaigned
you know almost 24 hours a day on
christmas day he'd be calling people you
know voters and just saying you know
Nancy and I were just here thinking
about you and there's photographers in
Columbia who took a photograph of him
one day on a Saturday and Thurman I was
long after he'd become centers and
promised if he had a car just want him
to drive him around for about three
hours because he knew the way in Strom
wasn't so sure about the streets and he
had a little boot notebook and he'd call
out these addresses and he'd go up and
knock on the door and leave a card you
know find somebody a physician mowing
his lawn and walk over and talk to them
and pat him on the back and move on to
the next one for just constant
campaigning that was his life and he did
genuinely like to help people you also
you know he he was also shaped about
very much by his father I mean edgefield
produced ten governors of South Carolina
including Thurman and drama once said
his father would have been elected
governor quote except he had to kill a
man one time
could you run today
at what age I mean just say younger and
I mean could he be elected today in
today's the way the media is and
everything else strong as a man who
mastered retail politics on a statewide
basis I mean just constant if you have
looked at Thurmond closely when he was
when line of people and he was shaking
hands people were going through it he'd
always been looking at the next person
while he's shaking this one's hand
because he could detect a glint of
recognition and thermal would always say
so good to see you again and I mean and
plus the the constituent service when
photograph and L ran against him quote
said you know he'd have these people
would say plug you know I agree with
everything you say but I can't forget
the time my mother needed up this
prescription and Strom got the druggist
to open the drugstore on a Saturday
night how to get my mother in the
hospital in a critical situation and you
know you could suddenly hundred thousand
of those constituent services and last
time you ran of gets Elliott closer when
someone that one of closest a fundraiser
just asked the question he was a little
bit being mischievous and asked how many
people in here have ever gotten help
from Strom Thurmond you know hands
started going up at almost every table
and that stuff just you know that's what
saved in the last time if he were
younger again yeah he would adapt to
current circumstances he was adapt
you mentioned how good he is with his
supporters but it seems like in the past
quarter century he's the only candidate
that refused to ever be in debates if he
was so bold as a politician why did he
not be confronted by other people on
issues he might not be able to defend as
well as he would like that was not his
strong point and he was he was bold on
issues but he was he also was had the
political astuteness to know that that
was not going to be his strong point and
he would strong would simply say you
know I don't believe in giving my
opponent publicity was he personally a
friend of any particular southern
politicians that whose names we might
know what I mean just what he was a
crony of the parties but was there any
any particular political figures that he
was personally friendly with I mean as a
matter of personal friendship I don't
think he had that type of relationship
on a personal friendship basis with many
other politician there were certainly
people he agreed with he agreed with
Barry Goldwater a hundred percent on the
issues and you know and that's when he
switched parties in 1964 was to support
Barry Goldwater as a Republican
candidate now Goldwater had voted
against the 1964 Civil Rights Act but
Thurman also agreed with him on national
defense any communism and a whole host
of other issues but in terms of a close
personal relationship I don't think he
had too much of that with other members
he was actually think it was the first
cousin once removed of son-of-a Herman
Talmadge of Georgia but they weren't
really close politically I mean they
were closed politically and then they
were friendly but it was not you know
the sort of close somebody we invite
over for dinner on a regular basis that
sort of thing
Joseph Biden them if you probably went
to the funeral delivered that eulogy
right at hit and he obviously had a
long-term relationship with strong was
an interesting matchup Thurman Biden did
have a long-term relationship with Biden
and the two of them got along very well
and Thurman Thurman was would not you
know he would not one of these highly
partisan Republicans he believed in
working across the aisle but that was
that was more than Norman in those days
all this really you know high-pitched
level of partisanship is relatively new
in the Senate and and Biden's I mean
Biden's eulogy and we have extended
excerpts in the book from it pretty a
pretty powerful he thought Thurman with
someone other senators felt they could
trust that he gave his word he'd keep it
if he said he was going to be with you
you knew he would he was going to stay
with you and and that was an important
characteristic and even though despite
his having played the key role in
Richard Nixon getting the nomination and
also a key role in his election when
after Watergate began thurmond was one
of the very first members of Congress to
say you know they better get their story
straight are they going to be in deep
trouble and he's a kind it is a it is a
complicated life and in the relationship
with ses it was complicated because he
did provide support for her and but it
was it was never acknowledged and she
never you know he said they never so
much has had a meal together but she saw
him you know she'd seem regularly when
he'd go to California he would call and
meet with her and made it a point to
meet her children but also knew that he
never really really got to know those
grandchildren and I met her in 1997 in
California I went to her home and when
she realized exactly I'd written her a
letter but when she realized who
was and what i wanted it would just pull
the old family friends is old family
friends and she had an errand to run and
when she did her press conference in
columbia a year and a half ago but saw
her daughter and just introduced myself
and she said she thought her mother
would like to see me so i've spent a
fair amount of time talking to her and
doing some visiting with her and she's a
very she's a very interesting woman has
made a tremendous impression on this
state and when she went to edgefield the
first time after all of this I mean it
was a really a hero's welcome home big
front-page stories on both of the town's
weekly newspapers and you know the most
prominent citizen in town escorting her
around it's a it's fascinating and when
the fascinating things to me is you know
what what the lasting will there be any
lasting impact of this whole
relationship between him and su in
particular her role and how well she's
been received in sort of just softening
and having a healing effect on race
relations in this state wasn't it common
knowledge a long time ago even amongst
the black community that he had this
daughter and that he was supporting her
and that's kind of softened the feeling
most common knowledge among the black
community 30 year at least 30 years ago
that was probably when mr. Mill's first
came out this was the editor of the
edgefield advertiser who had gotten a
big dispute with Senator Thurmond on the
front page of his newspaper which then
was suffering from a total advertising
boycott that was connected to his
dispute with Thurmond on a local issue
and said Strom Thurmond has colored
offspring big biggest type he had
growing down the front page of his paper
and I can tell this story I guess I
wrote I wrote that story for the
Charlotte observant editors just said no
you know it's not quite now I think I
sent it in a second time I think he
called mr. Mims Colton and they said no
and so I said ok
then I went campaigning with him October
of 1972 and it's been a full day with
sunderland you said oh come on back out
with me tomorrow I'll be going in to
help country I saw something I think
I've got a butt campaign with him with
something else I mean just obscene him
on the campaign trail nothing like it
you know I remember we hit Anderson yet
in this aid who's now chief judge of the
Fourth Circuit Court of Appeals it's
been saying and Sunday we've got this
appointment in Greenville got to get to
the plane he said we've got to go by the
code house is what Strom said and they
went in there and he ran into the
probate judge and almost knocked him out
of his chair I slapped him on the back
and say you remember we used to room
across the hall from each other at
Clemson this magistrate was holding
Courtin Strom shakes the magistrate's
hand it looked like a kid about 12 or 13
who's been breaking some windows with
rocks or something to the schoolhouse
and his mother was there and shook the
little boy's hand shook the woman's hand
and went on the woman's I didn't know
it's going good to see Strom Thurmond
would have come here today I mean it
just a zoom right through it but that
that was the day I went out with in the
second time because when I got back to
my office after the first day mr. Mims
had announced on television as a
write-in candidate holding his newspaper
in front of him and I said oh it's now
news i wrote it and said oh my goodness
I didn't quite use that language but I
said means tomorrow morning I've got to
I got to be out of the airport at six
o'clock if I wrote the story and got out
there and one other reporter was there
to campaign manager and Strom was
outside reading a different reading the
state news there which had no story only
the Charlotte Observer ran a story and
would like a movie scenes drum slowly
lowered the tapering of his face and he
said mr. bass did you know that
repeating the libels in itself a libel
and we all drown the plane and drunk
flew off and you know and he was he was
out campaigning for 15 hours
his remarkable memory for names he just
if you'd see you want to really have
some code of a conversation with you
you'd see him two years later in detail
I remember seeing you went to college
then you call you by name or do you just
remember seeing you that's cuz that's
good you know you did have no that's
true he did have a very remarkable
memory for names and even before he got
into politics when he was a high school
teacher he ran this summer camp and he
had 300 boys and he told him he was
gonna call him each by name and if he
didn't they could run him through the
beltline and when the teachers said he's
going to be governor one day when he was
governor the efforts he made for the
black students of South Carolina when he
was governor he when his I said when he
became governor his first year he was he
was characterized nationally as the
liberal governor of South Carolina the
last lynching occurred in South Carolina
to two months after his inauguration and
he ensured there was a very vigorous
prosecution nobody was convicted but
there was a strong there was a strong
powerful lesson and in Greenville the
subject of a very long article by
Rebecca West in The New Yorker called
opera and Greenville but there's never
been it was never any lynching after
that I remember to the day he died I
happened to be driving to Rock Hill
South Carolina and had the radio on in
the entire time they had an open mic and
phone calls were coming in and coming in
and coming in even people i knew were
calling and then some of course most i
didn't know you were listening do you
remember that man from Massachusetts who
called in and said I have just driven
across South Carolina and I have been
listening on my radio to these people
witnessing to this man and the goodies
done for South Carolina and the people
of South Carolina black and white and he
said
we didn't know that Massachusetts I've
just been introduced to a man I didn't
even know and I thought I knew Thurman
something to that effect and I thought
good yeah actually I did listen to much
of that I mean I attended the funeral
but there was one story that I thought
was that one young man one man called
had been a young man many years earlier
he worked the senator thurmond as really
as a teenager probably 18 and 19 and was
driving him to Charleston from Columbia
and Thurman who had a notorious record
as a backseat driver kept saying pastor
fasting are we going to slow guy go
faster and finally blue light comes on
Highway Patrol pulls off God pulls off
the side road patrolman gets out of his
car and start walking and Strom jumps
out the car and says he's going to slow
you need to get me to Charleston I'm
Strom Thurmond I got an appointment I
need you to drive me you know patrolman
looks up and he says he calls
headquarters you know in motion to get
in they take off for Charleston there
was a boldness there anyone else
you know at the end of his life you know
George Wallace did apologize for his
segregationist views and some of the
things he did did Strom ever apologize
for his views no I said I think the long
time he was in denial but i think that
funeral in the way he planned it that's
not was my interpretation at the time in
the sense of it when the way it was all
planned when these was amazing grace in
that line is about to save a wretch like
me it was written by song was written by
a slave slave ship captain from the
north and it just struck me that that
was the message drom was trying to send
their he mean he was complex in many
ways they always there was a certain
even naive quality he had at times and
but he was also it was more subtle tea
his mind was more subtle than certainly
that I had realized for many years and I
don't mean to say that his legacy was
perfect by any means you know there you
can make their case can be made you know
it was an argument that you know Strom
did a great deal to really hardened the
state's resistance the whole South's
resistance to the civil to the civil
rights movement of Education was
determined at the southern manifesto his
strong denunciation of the Civil Rights
Acts of the Voting Rights Act but then
he voted for the 25 year renewal of the
Voting Rights Act in 1982 and he told SC
once that his relationship with her made
it a lot easier for me tell Armstrong
Williams you know persuade me why I
should do this and so he's he was
complicated and he would always ask me
include me you see any Senators present
day who come near doing or being what
strom thurmond was
I'd say senator john mccain has some of
that scene independence I think that
Strom exhibited I mean you know in his
last couple decades last probably 15 or
20 years it was pretty much just a
straight Republican vote on almost every
issue but but there were exceptions
there were exceptions and Strom absorbed
things through osmosis and Tom moss
understood that mr. Moss never to
suggested a Strom how he vote on
anything but he would expose him to
circumstances he would bring him you
know he'd meet with the black mayors he
would he would meet with light with the
black college presents from this state
and he would listen and and and he did
you know he was he finally thought they
ought to be a some black person honored
by Congress we this is a 1982 now this
is you know 14 years after the death of
Martin Luther King most takes him to
Voorhees College in Denmark South
Carolina and Thurman talks and he
mentions booker t washington he'd
actually heard Booker T barking speaking
strong as they use you know there was
sort of silence and he mentions George
Washington Carver silence he mentions
the name of Martin Luther King the
plates are sortable feel erupted but you
know people reacting and Strom said you
know they really like him don't be I
mean but it took that experience for him
to really get it in that sense what is
your sense of
the memory of Strom Thurmond in the
black community I think it's mixed I
think the SEMA is coming forward has
been very very well received in the
black community in the white community
there are exceptions not everybody you
know is enthralled with it but
overwhelmingly you know a lot of blacks
means that it made them feel better for
coming out and it so you know I think I
see even a connection with what happened
report last week there was a beat there
was a significant event in abbeville
South Carolina where a major linking
occurred and it was cited that
particular lynching was cited when the
Senate he should have us in addition its
apology a month or so long ago and a
white Minister really initiated this
meeting and it was really coming
together white and blackened and the
mayor of the town went to an address the
group and apologized and in you know to
the reporters knowledge is a very good
reporter that it never happened before
anywhere in the United States and and I
I'm inclined to think that Thurman's
that relationship has become more
understood has made it a little easier
to break the silence for many many years
and for too many years i think you know
in south carolina and much of the south
just been a silence about really talking
about race people have been afraid of it
in part and I think we're developing
more openness and my my perception is
this whole relationship of Strom and
Essie Mae and the reaction of his family
and how they've handled it Strom
Thurmond jr. I think has taken the lead
on that in recognizing her heritage and
accepting her as their sister and has
also played a significant role in in
opening up people's attitudes a lot of
Oh be silent and was on a one-by-one
basis but I think that that may be
I think it is I think that ends up being
part of his legacy I saw a film not too
long ago in the director said he had
always been intrigued by Lyndon Johnson
but he had resisted for many years
making a film about him because he
didn't like him he thought he'd led us
down the road to a misdirected raw and
he said but the more he came to know him
he became of the opinion that the wall
was a situation where Johnson was caught
on the horns of a dilemma where he felt
like he needed to take us to war in
order to get elected but it was a
terrible distraction from what he really
wanted to do which was the civil rights
act and he thought beneath it all he was
a misjudged man of compassion is that
mean is that there's a possibility that
Strom Thurmond at some point in the
future will come to be looked upon is
something other than the personification
of the Old South it's a good question i
think we don't know until we see how the
future looks back and judges him but you
know he's like a tree with many rings
and his roots certainly are in the Old
South in the deep south and yet he did
adjust to changing circumstances and and
I think that type of growth really in a
sense is part of that legacy and you
know but Thurman never apologized
anything you know it just wasn't that
was something that probably comes out of
the edgefield tradition you know you
mean the apology might just be in the
form of different behavior and behavior
team but also when he changes when he
did make that change and you know with
hiring tom moss it was after the 1970
campaign for governor in South Carolina
when Thurman's almost hand-picked
candidate albert watson congressman ran
what some Republicans even called a
racist campaign and he lost and it
reflected a changing attitude among the
voters of the state and people were
telling Thurman that and he pursued he
would have perceived it on his own as
well but some of his closest advisors
were telling him that and Harry den is
the one who suggested hiring Tom lost
Thomas had been director of the voter
education project in South Carolina he
was responsible for getting registered
those tens of thousands of black voters
who helped defeat albert watson and he'd
also been president of a biracial labor
union local in orangeburg south carolina
meat packers local and and Thurman
decided and that's the man he wanted
carry on any part of his legacy well he
says Strom Thurmond has two sons neither
active in politics Strom Thurmond jr.
served i think it was three years as US
attorney and by all accounts did an
exemplary job he's back practicing law
in Aiken and whether he runs decides to
run or not remains to be seen Thurman
always told his children if they wanted
to get in politics he would support them
and if they didn't they should didn't
want to do it then don't do it his other
son lives in Charleston he's a
prosecuting attorney for the solicitor's
office and there's been speculation he
may someday run for office and if he did
if he does he would be a very attractive
candidate my question is you a lot of
what you say about Strom seems to be a
comment on the character of the people
in Edgefield and I'm wondering a youth
marriage feel how did you understand the
character of the people with no I'm not
from it I grew up in a very small town
in the state though not that terribly
far from edgefield so growing up and you
know you absorb a certain understanding
of the culture so I thought I felt I
understood edgefield then spent a fair
amount of time over there and but when
you get the more deeply and going to the
history of Edgefield it's it's unlike I
say any other
I mean the cemetery where Strom Thurmond
is buried you've got the Civil War
governor of South Carolina who had been
US ambassador to Russia before that and
his daughter who is known as dooshka
because she was she was born in Russia I
was not a formal million but at least
and she led the red shirt campaign which
is the violet political campaign of 1876
is over through the reconstruction
regime you have Preston Brooks who came
Charles Sumner of Massachusetts and then
consciousness on the floor the Senate in
1857 because he had offended Brooks
uncle senator senator Andrew thickens
Butler of South Carolina on whose
plantation as his maternal grandfather
was a slave so you have all these
connections and it's I mean putting this
story together with just fascinated like
finding out first you had to like an
Easter egg hunt looking for a piece of a
jigsaw puzzle then finally getting
enough of them and getting to fit the
pieces together with all these pieces
and some so tiny and some so extravagant
it is there after all is said and done
not to minimize one single thing is
there a lesson from this extraordinary
man there are many lesser men and
there's a strength here that maybe we
all do well to learn something from I
think there is but i think i think a
reader would have to draw that
conclusion for themselves and and i
think what you come away with is this is
someone whose life mattered whether you
like it or dislike it and that the
authors really left that for the reader
to make those judgments but i think we
positioned the reader to make them now
one the relationship was from in SC my
co-author not disagree on that one
maryland thompson really views it as
strong with exploited SE and and and
bought her silence with his financial
support
I think it's more complex than that now
go back to their first real meeting in
1941 and Edgefield when this his birth
mother brought her back and she had a
long relationship the mother had a long
relationship with Strom Thurmond and and
and she brought her daughter back from
Pennsylvania where she grown up with an
aunt with her mother's sister to a
family funeral of another sister and
carry but little mother Strom Thurmond
at this time as a state Circuit Court
Judge plan to run for governor and Kari
goes and tells him put you in effect you
know I'd like your daughter's here and I
like for you to meet him now he had a
choice he had a choice he could have
said he could have told her I don't even
know you and in Edgefield South Carolina
and 1941 Carrie Butler would have been
totally helpless to do anything about it
totally powerless instead he said okay
and she brought SE over and yes he
didn't know her father was white until
he walked into the into the waiting room
and and he turned to it turns to her
mother and she look he looks at asking
turns 21 so that's a very attractive
looking very attractive daughter you
have in this moment of silence and the
mother says she's your daughter too and
then he talks to about you know when she
plans to do after school and this sort
of thing to take care of a health and
eat the right foods and all of that but
there was no no you know no outward
display of affection but it was that
there was a connection and it was it was
complex plated so I think it I think it
is more complicated not I think he did
regret that he was unable to have but
when you know when he was governor and
she was a student at South Carolina
State College now South Carolina State
University in orangeburg he would come
and visit and bring his wife Jean and
and she would come to Colombian go
shopping he paid her tuition and paid
her expenses and she'd go shopping at
what was then the best department store
in Colombian driver same
Robin Hood taken suit load to the death
chamber was drama in the back seat the
hugging and the kissing the whole way
but he was by this time he was he was
chief of colored quote chief of colored
help close quote at the Statehouse he
dropped ekasi up at the train station
driving back to the governor's office
and you know it was just it was so much
separation in two different cultures in
two different worlds at Thurman with his
supreme sense of self-confidence you
know felt he was okay nobody's going to
say anything any black person says it
and the white person will believe him
anyway and they'll be afraid to talk if
they've thought about it and it was just
that sort of taboo and separate sense of
separation but it say it's complicated
well I just want to thank everybody very
much